hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
destiny 2 is touching distance away and
at this point you'll probably already
know if you're going to buy it or not
but you may not be sure which platforms
best for you it's going to be difficult
for gamers to turn down that slick 60
frames per second only offered by the PC
experience but PlayStation have
maintained their relationship with
Activision and have a truckload of
exclusives which Xbox and PC just won't
get their hands on for at least a year
after PlayStation whatever platform you
choose you're going to have a cracking
time but let's quickly break down all
the content we'll be receiving on the
PlayStation 4 you will find an
additional competitive multiplayer map a
three player Corp strike a unique ship
three specialized gear sets and an
exclusive exotic weapon I'm starting
with that exotic weapon because this
looks insanely good in a universe where
elemental damage is imperative that this
bad boy will have your back it possesses
all three damage types the borealis can
switch between solar void and arc at
will making it a top tier weapon for any
self-respecting sniper
in terms of looking unique in destiny
we've always had awesome armor sets to
switch up and mix around on PlayStation
you'll find access to three more
exclusive gear sets for you Titan men's
out there there is Terra Concorde which
isn't too shabby at all the warlocks
receive the tesseract race which is
pretty sexy but my fellow hunters we
will get our hands on the Icarus drifter
which will look amazing once I've
applied my bright pink shader to it our
PlayStation 4 players will also be able
to take a charge of the city
apex shift - this cute little number
comes in a snazzy metallic blue and
white perfect for your interstellar
travel there's even more to an exclusive
crucible map aptly named retribution is
also available on the PlayStation in
which large acts have taken over a fleet
of the red legions capital ships and
using them for training guardians and
finally the exclusive strike mission
takes place in the European dead zone
here on earth and hassles resisting a
taken threat attempting to claim an area
from our grasp
the lake of Shadows we'll also see our
Guardians preventing the red Legion from
constructing a bridge which opens time
could that sound any more epic a quick
note that destiny chose release date has
we pushed forward a couple of days to
September the 6th as always PlayStation
users who are pre-ordered will get early
access to the beta on July 18th before
any other platforms what do you think -
this additional content on PlayStation
happy delighted delirious ecstatic or
are you against the whole console
exclusives thing I'm bloody happy about
this one especially that sexy sniper
rifle let's just look at it one more
time oh it's gorgeous
roll on September the stick I imagine
from PlayStation grenade it's been a
pleasure I'll see you next time